An organization with as many secrets as
the SCP Foundation requires the ability
to dispose of material that could prove harmful
to the facade of normalcy that the 05 council
desperately wishes to uphold. And because most
of the high-ranking researchers are a bit too
smart and practical to simply flush classified
documents and unwanted objects down the toilet,
the means that the Foundation uses to get
rid of evidence has to be thorough enough
to guarantee that absolutely no trace of
what needs to be disposed of survives.
For this purpose, several waste disposal plants
are used as front companies for The Foundation,
and function internally as a foolproof way to
liquidate hazardous material and compromising
information. But not all secrets are so
easily forgotten with the push of a button,
and a rare few can prove too resilient to
be burned away. This is the regrettable
case of the anomalies contained with the
site now designated SCP-2419 - a place
where the unfortunate consequence of amnestic
experiments has led to the creation of hateful
immortal humanoids fated to be sealed
within the incinerators of the facility.
These undead freaks are known as SCP-2419-A,
and though they were made from human bodies,
the consciousness that dwells within each
instance is nothing short of pure evil.
Every happy memory and associated positive
emotion was extracted from the brains of
SCP-2419-A corpses prior to their attempted
disposal in the incinerators. This was done
in order to increase the effectiveness
of standard issue Foundation amnestics,
but the cost of this minor breakthrough was
that these bodies - all of which were once
D-Class personnel - had effectively been stripped
of all human qualities. Given the sorts of violent
criminal backgrounds that earns an individual the
designation of D-class personnel, these former
humans were the last people that should have been
deprived of the love and joy in their hearts.
And when the first of these psychopathic Laughing
Men crawled out of one of SCP-2419’s incinerators,
the Foundation learned all too well what
an uninhibited criminal mind looked like.
Driven only by the rage and fury that inspired
their most gruesome acts of exploitation and
violence in life, their pain has made them
too hateful to succumb to the flames. They
are the archetypal sinners of a burning hell
that the Foundation’s best intentions paved
the road to. And when they break loose,
all that hell breaks loose with them.
But no place of the damned leaves its gates
unguarded. Dante’s Inferno posits that the ancient
Greek mythological figure Minos, serpentine
father of the minotaur and judge of wicked souls,
guards the pit of Hell with stern vigilance. The
Greeks themselves favored the image of cerberus,
a three-headed hound that served its lord hades
as a watchdog. For the ancient Egyptians, there
was Ammut, the devourer of the dead, who consumed
the hearts of the unrighteous in the afterlife.
While this sort of guardian beast is not
officially on the Foundation’s payroll,
the concept turned out to be alive
and well in the present day when
SCP-682 - the hard-to-destroy reptile
- stood against the Laughing Man and
gave them the fight of their
tortured unliving existence.
It all began when the guards stationed at SCP-2419
began to hear banging from the inside of one of
the incinerators. It seemed as though the
SCP-2419-A instance on the other side was
determined to breach containment, so
Mobile Task Force Beta-7 - “The Maz
Hatters” - were called in to stand with
all weapons at the ready. But this was
exactly what the instance wanted. As soon
as the armed force had fully assembled,
the Laughing Man inside ripped the metal door
from its hinges. It proceeded to use it as
cover and run full speed towards the mobile
task force, who opened fire immediately.
SCP-2419-A were known to possess
extremely fast regenerative abilities,
so it would take a lot of punishment to slow this
instance down. But this was no unthinking zombie,
and the instance broke its charge the second it
was in the midst of the mobile task force agents
to twirl the door around like a trained martial
artist. This not only sent the incoming bullets
ricocheting everywhere - causing many of the
Beta-7 operatives to be hit by their own friendly
fire - it also allowed the instance to bludgeon
several agents with the sides of the door.
As the remaining mobile task
force members retreated to a
less exposed vantage point where
they could employ heavy artillery,
the instance used this moment of confusion
to pitch the door backwards towards the
incinerators in a boomerang trajectory. The
force and spin of the door knocked two more
incinerator doors off their hinges, and caused
two other instances of SCP-2419-A to emerge.
One, who was so thoroughly decomposed that
it appeared to be little more than a flaming
skeleton, sprinted forth and threw handfuls of
hot cinders at the Foundation agents. It used its
still-burning body to ignite a few of the closest
agents, laughing with sadistic glee as it did so.
Seconds after the emergence of the two new
instances, a grenade launcher was fired at
the first escapee. The blast was enough to
deal significant damage, but the instance
was indifferent to its own pain. It pointed
to the agent wielding the grenade launcher
and a moment later, the third instance was at
the agent's throat, strangling him to death.
It was starting to become clear to the
Mobile Task Force that this was no random
containment breach. It was a coordinated escape
attempt by three ruthless criminal masterminds,
who in their time contained at the
site SCP-2419 had probably decided
there was some truth to the old adage
that “misery loves company.” And indeed,
these three D-class were some of the best of the
best when it came to being the worst of the worst.
D-1576 - Formerly Police Lieutenant Campbell
Farage, a riot cop with a serious taste for
carnage. Whenever the streets of the city
precinct he presided over turned violent,
Farage always made sure that the violence didn’t
die down too quickly. His nasty penchant for
bludgeoning suspects and citizens alike with his
riot shield did wonders for the escape plan he
had coordinated with his fellow Laughing Men.
He was eventually tried and sent to a supermax
after picking a fight with several other officers
in the line of duty, a fight that resulted in a
pair of rookie officers who opposed his violent
methods being hospitalized with permanent comas.
The skeleton was D-4483 - Damien Lambert,
a prolific arsonist who terrorized three
counties while avoiding detection under the guise
of being a sovereign citizen. If there was ever a
person who just wanted to watch the world burn, it
was Damien Lambert. He was caught in the process
of setting fire to an elementary school, and
was thankfully apprehended before any of the
kerosene he had poured through the halls ignited.
When the truth about his previous history of
pyromania came out, Lambert faced death row until
the Foundation chose to recruit him as a D-class.
Then, there was D-2316 - Arnold Roper - who
was better known as The Illinois Strangler,
responsible for over 50 deaths in
two decades before he was arrested
and detained. While he mostly used his
bare hands to do the deed, Roper was fond
of using metal chains and heavy-duty choke
collars usually worn by animals to perform
his namesake act of violence. Roper wasn’t
just brutally strong, he was crafty too,
and the trio of laughing men had him to thank
for some of the finer points of the escape plan.
These three now-immortal D-class also had one
other thing in common: each of them had met
the ends of their cruel and violent lives at
the jaws and claws of SCP-682. And now that
they had outmaneuvered and slaughtered Mobile
Task Force Beta-7, their only collective goal
was to get revenge on the monster that condemned
them all to the fiery hell of the incinerator.
The Laughing Men soon breached the limits
of the SCP-2419 containment site and began
making their way overland towards the facility
where all of them had met their original fate.
They knew they needed wheels to get there, so
instances made their way to the nearest gas
station to the waste disposal plant they’d
come from and made short work of the staff.
Lambert stocked up on lighters, kerosene, and
duraflame, while Farage took the emergency
shotgun that the cashier hadn’t
had time to fire. In her defense,
it would have been difficult to accomplish
much of anything with Roper’s hands clasped
around her throat. Once the trio of undead
psychopaths had stocked up on weapons,
they waited for a suitable vehicle to pull
into the lot. And before long, there it was.
A family SUV, with a happy family inside,
no less. Farage ordered Lambert to keep
his fire-starting tendencies in check, as a
gas station explosion was the last thing they
needed right now. The former riot cop made
his way out to the car and used the shotgun
to threaten the family out of the car. Family
road trips can be stressful, but rarely does
one expect to be carjacked by a gang of the
undead. Farage told the unlucky mortals that
he wouldn’t hurt them if they let himself and his
two friends use their car, and true to his word,
he didn’t fire a single shot. The family were
all added to Roper’s list of victims instead.
After that, the bad men took the wheel
and - with only their hazy memories of
pain and suffering to guide them - drove
relentlessly towards the Foundation Facility
where their enemy SCP-682 was contained.
The three had made sure to leave no human
alive at their original containment
site and would allow no witnesses who
saw their anomalous corpse-like forms to
survive. They couldn’t afford to give the
Foundation a heads up that the reckoning
was on its way in a family motor vehicle.
Meanwhile, at the Laughing
Men’s intended destination,
SCP-682 was having another perfectly
routine day of painfully soaking in
a tank of corrosive acid. This was
par for the course for the reptile,
and it found itself as eager as anyone stuck in a
rut to get a break from the repetitive mundanity
of containment. Little did the human-hating
monster know, it would soon get its wish.
A few hours later, the facility was shocked
to find that several fires had been lit at
the fringes of the testing units. These were no
freak accidents, but rather the work of Damien
Lambert. The arsonist still had memories
of all the times he wished he could have
burned his jailor’s buildings to the ground
and had targeted the most vulnerable areas
for combustion. The flames threatened the
integrity of several areas of the facility,
and multiple containment breaches were imminent
if the blaze couldn’t be kept under control.
While any available agents with fire-fighting
experience sought to minimize the damage,
the researchers evacuated to safer parts
of the building, bringing any sensitive
documents and flammable items far away from the
affected sections. This kind of pandemonium was
exactly where Officer Farage thrived,
and he soon entered the fray, causing
enough commotion that Roper was able to slip
deeper into the facility completely undetected.
This turned out to be the perfect role for the
Strangler, as he hadn’t eluded the police for
twenty years of his life just by being lucky.
Farage and Lambert would both join up with him
after they were finished having their fun. For
now, his task was to locate the containment unit
of SCP-682 and give the beast a taste of
what the trio had in store. Along the way,
he made sure to obtain some durable metal
chains from a different containment unit.
He likely released some kind of elder evil in
the process, but Roper didn’t care about the
consequences. The bottom line was that he was
always able to do best work when he was armed.
It wasn’t long before he found the large
chamber which housed his most hated foe:
SCP-682. Roper laughed maniacally as he
approached the creature floating in its acid tank.
“Remember me, lizard?” The strangler
said, sporting a wide grin.
The monster simply growled back at Roper,
wishing to tear him apart. Roper chuckled again,
and wrapped the iron chains around the
vat. With all the considerable strength
of his immortal muscles, the strangler
pulled the chains taught and shattered
SCP-682’s containment unit. The anomalous chains
snared the creature's body, holding it in place.
“How about now?” Roper taunted 682. He
laughed, but the creature laughed back.
“No,” said the reptile. “I don’t
remember you, but you are disgusting.”
The monster lunged towards a nearby wall
and burst through, dragging Roper along
with it by his chains still wrapped around
the creature’s body. 682 twisted and turned,
flinging Roper against every wall and
obstacle in sight, but to its surprise,
the strangler was regenerating, and
his grip on the chains was unyielding.
Back down the hall, Farage was still
continuing his rampage when he ran into
an unlikely adversary. Dr. Alto Clef stood between
the Laughing Man and the other researchers, and as
usual, the good doctor was packing heat. He told
the other researchers to go on without him while
he contained the SCP-2419 instance on his own. A
bold move, to be sure, but Dr. Clef had made the
same mistake he was always making by assuming
that guns were the solution to this problem.
Farage laughed off the bullets and slammed
into Dr. Clef with enough force to leave a
crater in the wall behind him. He followed
up with a merciless barrage of punches,
beating the armed researcher senseless
and only relenting for a moment to steal
a few of his prized firearms. With a blow that
would have taken the life of any normal man,
Farage struck Dr. Clef once more and
left him lying there a hair’s length
from death. Dr. Clef’s anti-anomaly field
may have protected him from reality warpers,
but it did very little against being
kicked repeatedly, very hard, in the face.
Elsewhere, Lambert had made
his way inside the facility,
setting more fires as he went. The arsonist’s
skeleton was a terrifying sight to all that
beheld it and when the guards realized that
none of their weapons would have an effect,
most of them started to run away
from Lambert rather than towards him.
All three laughing men would soon
be upon SCP-682, and then the fight
of their afterlives could truly begin.
Until that moment, Roper was buying his
partners in hatred more time. The chains he had
stolen were no ordinary metal, and with them,
he had managed to keep 682’s jaws shut while
he pounded away at its exposed ribs with his
inhuman strength. Roper had killed more people
than either of his former D-class compatriots,
but all of that seemed to mean nothing
in the face of this invincible reptile.
The shame and powerlessness he had once felt
as the creature had mauled him to death made
his immortal heart beat with outrage. When
he was alive, the Illinois Strangler had
always thought that his gift for murder made him
better than the average person: a man among men.
But this thing had made him feel weak in his
last moments of humanity, and that sickening
emotion of weakness was still sliding around in
his soul with all of the other despair and malice.
If his fate were to live forever as a
dead man walking, then he would make
damn sure that any humiliation he suffered
would be paid back threefold. This soup of
impotent fury bubbled within Roper as
SCP-682’s strength suddenly increased,
shattering the weak link of the chains and
sending the hapless strangler flying backwards.
At that precise moment, Farage leaped
out of a nearby hallway and unleashed
Dr. Clef’s arsenal on the reptile. This
sustained fire irritated the creature,
and it turned its focus towards the unliving
dirty cop. It readied a charge only to be
suddenly held fast by Roper, who had grabbed its
tail. Farage fired until there was no more ammo,
then pistol-whipped the creature
in both of its eye sockets.
SCP-682 thrashed and struggled, so the men
began to circle the reptile and alternate
delivering formidable body blows. They took
far more damage than they could dish out with
their bare hands, but the regeneration
that their preternatural hatred granted
them meant that both instances could
theoretically keep this up all day.
Roper grabbed a broken length of the
anomalous chain, while Farage picked
up a metal table for use as a makeshift
riot shield. The beatdown continued as
SCP-682’s eyes regenerated, along
with several new sensory organs to
give it a full 360-degree view of the
pitched brawl that was taking place.
A fiery explosion blew open a
nearby wall, and in walked Lambert,
still skeletal and laughing as uproariously as
ever. He threw a Molotov cocktail at 682’s back,
causing the creature to ignite immediately.
The reptile roared in sudden agony.
Farage, Lambert, Roper regrouped at the
creature’s flank and pushed together until
they forced it back through the hole
where the arsonist had entered from.
They were now altogether in the inferno
- the three laughing men who refused to
die and the indestructible monster
that made them into what they were.
Roper quickly knotted the chains and wrapped
them around one of the creature’s claws,
securing the other end around his waist.
Like a trained boxer, he bobbed and weaved,
pummeling the beast with all he had. Any
step back from SCP-682 was meant with the
immortal man shifting his entire body weight
to pull the creature’s leg out from under it.
Farage wedged his shield into the creature’s
open jaw, widening it to an uncomfortable
degree and temporarily limiting 682’s bite
force. He took out the shotgun he had stolen
from the gas station and blasted it down the
reptile’s gullet. When that plan ran its course,
he started clubbing 682 about its neck
and head with the butt of the shotgun.
Lambert simply continued to douse the
area with more flammable material,
especially himself and the creature. He climbed
onto 682’s back with his burning bones and
hammered away at its defenses with literal
fists of fire. The arsonist was incapable
of articulate speech due to the damage to his
body prior to his death, but if he could speak,
he would probably be celebrating the fact that he
had become what he had always wanted to be. Damien
Lambert was no mere pretender with a fetish for
fire: he was fire itself. A brightly-burning god
of destruction that left no inch of the world
unburnt and no molecule of oxygen unconsumed.
His mother and father would be
proud of him as they waited in
Hell for the son who would never
arrive: the son who would make the
planet they left behind into a true
hell where he would reign supreme.
That is, until SCP-682 stole that dream out from
under him. With a flash of blue and green from
deep within, 682 began to burn with a never
before seen chemical reaction: an impossible
event that could only be described as anti-fire.
The turquoise anti-flames devoured the orange and
yellow ones, leaving Lambert in a state of panic -
which was soon shared by his fellow Laughing Men.
The three former D-Class had gotten so used
to the torments of the incinerator that the
idea that anything could be more painful had
never occurred to them. And yet, here it was,
the anti-fire, which devoured all flames and
directly inflicted unimaginable suffering to the
trio of instances. Every particle of their still
regenerating bodies felt like it was ice cold
and melting into nothingness at the same time.
Numbed and broken all over again, the laughing
men were consumed all over by the anti flames
and fell into a state of suspended animation.
With the Foundation finally getting
everything back under control 24 hours later,
SCP-682 was contained in a new acidic
chamber. There were some new ordinances
from all present and surviving researchers
about exposing it to fire - as the anti-flames
it produced were considered too hazardous
to ever exist within the facility again.
As for the three laughing men who had
escaped from SCP-2419: they were returned
to their containment units inside of the
incinerators and never exhibited signs of
aggression or escape attempts ever again.
A psychological profile of Farage, Lambert,
and Roper that all of them could still feel the
sting of the burns left by 682’s antifire to this
day, and that not even exposure to natural
heat and fire could ever reduce that pain.
Now go check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained
in the Backrooms?” and “Evil Monster Created
by SCP Foundation SCP-2419 - The Laughing Men” for
more of today’s terrifying combatants in action!